I asked Japanese people and foreigners living in Japan.
Summer in Japan
means yukata, right?
T-shirts stuck to your back. Shaved ice and
how much you ca
n't find. A trash can you can't find. The
cicada's voice understands the spontaneous combustion of the solar human body.
Cockroach attack and festival Goldfish scooping that fails no matter how many times I try
It must be a scam I'm suffering from
heatstroke
Barbecue The
smell of smoke on my clothes and hair It doesn't stick to my hair Fireworks Crowd
Sea and pool Diet Ramune Sake Beer
Calpis Beer Beer
Garden Beer garden Hmm,
playing in the river? The
sunrise starts at 4:30 on the summer solstice. A
bad sunburn at Koshien. Summer vacation Cool
Biz doesn't work. Looks
like it's job hunting. A
test of
courage. Lack of sleep due to fear. I
don't want to go to the tunnel, so I use the air conditioner.
Stupid electricity bill and a
mysterious cold. Fruit somen noodles.
Niigata
Diabetes
Diagnostic Aquarium A
dolphin key chain that will never be used.That's right.You're
good with Obon chopsticks.You're
good at Japanese.